Oh boi
Am I gonna regret this video..  yes you are...
*zoom in to face* *smile*
I've been up since 5 in the morning
I just got back from London
I'm fucking tired
But I gotta film a video today
And I've had this video..
in the back of my mind for a while
So I thought..
Hey, let's..
Let's get it out there
See what happens..
I'm gonna talk about my favorite animes *giggle*
*some animes opening scene*
HEY
I know what you're thinking..
Oh
Oh I see what he's doing
He's gonna bring up Naruto..
and Bleach. (the anime)
and he's gonna pretend he doesn't know which one is which
Oh that's..that's some gold standard..
pewdiepie comedy right there *giggle*
OH I GET IT
He's gonna bring up nineties..
American sitcoms..
and call them animes
That's..
that's a good humor..
I bet next he's gonna say his favorite anime is F.R.I.E.N.D.S
No..
but for real..
I used to watch a lot of anime *giggle*
*continue to laugh*
I know right?
*inhale*
What a fucking gaaa..
I'm sorry
CALM DOWN
I DON'T ANYMORE
I DON'T WATCH A LOT ANYMORE
There has been some good ones recently
Onepunch-Man,
Attack of The Titans was alright..
alright..
maybe you guys needs to calm down a lil' bit..
it was not fucking good..
Fucking tween
YOU THINK YOU KNOW ANIME ?
OHH I'M GONNA TELL YOU ANIME
OKAY
CAUSE I KNOW ! *roll*
I remember... the first anime I ever watched
Because I remember, I don't really used to get it..
I thought it was like..
weird
UGH
What is that..
weird Japanese shit..
I don't get it
Isn't that just for nerds ?!
*grabs hat*
Then I realize how fucking cool I was
*anime music*
*laugh*
Err..basically..
The first one I ever saw was "Ergo Proxy"
It was shown on..
Swedish television..
aaaand..
it was a sci-fi..
and I never really get into sci-fi as well
But I thought this was the coolest thing..
EVER
And I was so thrilled..
by the fact..
that I was enjoying watching it
IT HAS *pointing finger to camera*
THE BEST
INTRO
Oh man
It's so good
Fucking smallville..
type..
*intro song start*
"You complete my fate"
Yea I'm definitely regretting doing this video already
It also has..
The best..
most fitting outro I have ever seen
With Radiohead..
Paranoid Android..
which fit so good
It was the same thing I did..
I..I thought the same way about Radiohead
And then I got really into them
and it became one of my favorite bands
So..
you can say this anime..
introduce me to a whole new world..
which I never thought I would like
If I remember correctly..
the story is about..
a guy..
i..i...Mankind lives inside a bubble..
like this giant-ass glass bubble...
because we polluted the earth.. *that stare*
Original plot..
and then he falls out of the bubble..
and then he meets some new people..
but then he realized..
these things about himself..
that he didn't know before..
and there's like this weird..
people..
around..
*burst of laughter*
*inhale*
I really like it !
*more laugh*
Since..
since this whole video is embarrassing already..
let's just get..
the worst..
of the fucking worst..
out of the way..
ICHIGO 100%
If that..
If that rings a bell with you..
then we're on the same fucking level
*laugh*
Listen..
We be..
we be..
we be instant bros if you know Ichigo 100%
*laugh again*
Luckily I never met anyone else..
that are actually seen this fucking pathetic piece of shit anime *laugh again*
*anime starts*
It's basically the classic..
random-ass guy..
for some reason gets like 3..
hot girls..
who's into him..
which is like every guy's dream
Oh my gawd
*facepalm*
Oh yeah..
It's a lil' sexual, just a lil'..
it's very tastefully sexual, okay
OH SATSUKI
I remember..
It's all coming back to me now
Oh Toujou !
AAARGH
*laugh and inhale*
No spoilers, but..
he picks the wrong girl
OH NO *tears coming out gesture*
*laugh again and again*
WOOH
I'm glad we get that out of the way
Cause jesus christ..
that was pathetic
Okay
Let's move on to something..
COOLER~
Okay
BERSERK
Very famous anime..
very good
It's..it's..it's a bit old and..and..
you can tell on the style..
and usually that turns me off from watching older animes..
cause it they just..
UUGHH
They look like..
UUGGGHH
I don't like that
Doesn't have the fucking GIANT EYES
and bright colors
UGH I don't like that
But it's really good..
and I recommend it
It's a story about friendship and rivalry
*laugh again*
It has..
the..
biggest plot-twist..
or maybe not plot-twist
I don't know how to say
without spoiling..
but basically..
it starts out..
just completely normal medieval shit
You got horses..
you got swords..
you got armors..
you got battles..
EVERYTHING IS FINE
And you watch the anime..
up until..
a very e-end of episode 25
and you like
"Hey that's pretty co.."
"This is pretty coo.."
"This is pretty good"
and then..
Let's just say something happens..
and if you're under 18, DO NOT READ THE MANGA
Cause I read the manga..
And I saw some things
*traumatic poods*
And the m..the manga basically continues..
after the a..the anime ends..
Where this thing happens..
where everything just fucking changes
And
My..my poor..
my poor teenage eyes..
I saw some things..
I..I
They burnt into my retina..
No amount of bleach..
will able..
will ever..
cure..
Just don't read the manga
Just don't
I mean, do read the manga..
it's fucking great..
but just some part..
you might wanna click through
or erm, I mean..
Skip through a little fast *laugh*
That's all I'm saying
This a thing..
if you..if you read it you know exactly what I'm fucking talking about *laugh*
One thing about that's really cool about the manga..
once you get to a certain point..
is that you can see the influences that it had on..
some of my favorite games..
which is Dark Souls
Cause here's the armor
and you can see the resemblance to Artorias
As well
I think
And Artorias like the ultimate badass
Guts is the ultimate badass
So it's really cool..
You guys remember these ?
The wheels ?
From Dark Souls
Oh and The Hunt..The Hunter's Mark
The Hunter's Mark from Bloodborne
is straight..straight out from Berserk
And oh my god here's the part I was talking about..
JESUS FUCKING CHRIST
Yea we ne..we can't show that
Just no fucking way
And the trolls
Oh my God
It's just..fucking..too much man
I didn't know he got to fuck her
But it's really good !
It's really..
It's one of the best
It's probably one of the best
Another one that I really enjoyed was..
NH.."Welcome to the NHK!"
If I remembered it correctly..
basically..
I..I..I could relate so much to this guy while I watch..
Because he's a total introvert..
completely lost on what he's doing with his future..
He just want to be a shut-in..
and..escape from the world
ergh..I could relate to him so much
and I remember..
how it felt good in the way..
to..to..fully relate to what a character is struggling with
Loneliness, and oh my god..
I don't think this video could get more, uh, pathetic, but..
erh *laugh*
I just did it
Another favorite of mine is "Mononoke"
*zoom-in*
Shut the fuck up
Okay
No, I'm not talking about Princess Mononoke
EVERYTIME
All of you talking about is Princess Mononoke
"OH, I LOVE PRINCESS MONONOKE AS WELL!"
Well you fucking fake ass anime fan..
You haven't heard of "Mononoke" ?
Is that how you say it ? *laugh*
Okay
Erm
"Mononoke"..
is a collection of horror stories..
The art style is absolutely amazing..
It's one of the best I've ever seen
It's just incredible
It like bright, happy colors..
mixed with..
horror, it really..
gruesome horror stories
Somehow it works really well..
it's basically about a guy..
that's a medicine-man
And he travels around..
and he destroys his mononoke..
which is like demons or whatever
To kill them, he has to find out what happen
I love watching it, aand..
I really..I really recommend it
Just googling "Mononoke" and you fucking get all this shit
THIS IS NOT THE ONE !
THIS IS THE ONE !
I mean look..look at the art style
It's soo..it just so pretty
Another favorite of mine is..
"Gankutsuou"
I don't know if that's how you say it
Erm..it's basically..
The Count of Monte Cristo
They go hard on the fucking..the art style
they have these patterns..
that was made by some famous clothes designer
Why do I care ? *laugh*
I do care, that's why it's so sad
and, it's get some really fucking cheesy intro
OH OH
Jean-Jacques Burnel
NO NO
Oh, I just realized..
Berserk has the best fucking intro by the way
Just li..like these japanese people who can't speak English *laugh again and again*
Trying to sing a song
Like, why did they talk like that ?
*dancing poods*
"There's no blame, there's no fame"
"The first words should be found" *giggle*
What ?
Whateve..I didn't know this were the lyrics
"I can get it off..."
"Tell me what"
"Tell me what you waaan".. *giggle*
It's fucking good ! *thumbs up*
It's so good..
Look at them muscles man
OOH
Number 2 on my list
*scissor gesture*
"Kaiba"
Not a lot of people know about this anime
It's basically
It's a sci-fi
but a love story..
But, it's done in, uh..
Kind of Disney-inspired style..
The artwork
Which I
LOVE
It's so pretty
It's hard to find picture of this fucking anime as well..
Cause..because of this fucking guy..
Apparently his fucking name is Kaiba
But here's how the art style looks
I..I fucking love it
It's so pretty
Very interesting sci-fi story..
Where..
You..
Your body and memories..
Can be transferred to other people
Yea, the plot-twist got me..
Now I was very emotional at the end..
I hated the intro
The int..intro fucking sucks
It's really good
It's..it's got a good place in my heart
this anime
and uhm..
You don't have to judge me for it, okay
Just watch it yourself
It's kinda hard to watch
It's kinda hard to get into
So if you gonna watch this one..
you.. you..you gotta..you gotta give it a little go
Okay, finally
My favorite
Of everything
Oh boy..
I posted about this before, you might know of "Blame"
But Blame..
is the best thing ever created..
It's a cyber..
punk..
Cyber-punk ?
It's a story about a guy..
going through this..
uuhmm
endless..
landscape
there's very lil' dialogue
You basically have to kinda make..
up the story yourself..
or you kinda have to interpret it in your own way
Which is my favorite way of story telling
And I think that's why I like Bloodborne and Dark Souls so much..
Because..
Throw the story in your face you kinda have to just pay attention to what's going on
The way the scenery is drawn..
and..
uhm..
Manga is just absolutely incredible
The artist used to be an architect..
and you can tell..
because it so well, well uuhm, drawn
It has my favorite style of a manga
in..in any..thing i've ever read
It has one of the most interesting stories
I've ever read
I love to just come back
and re-read Blame..
because everytime I read it, it's a different interpretation
or you notice different things
and you discover new things
and you make it fresh everytime you...you go through it
And you can go through it in a couple hours
Because it's so little dialogue
It's fairly short
It has some of my favorite characters
I feel really weird talking about this..
because it feels so personal
that's why I'm like..
I don't..
It's my baby
One thing that's kinda weird, that I really like about Blame..
it's because, it has no nudity in it..
even though it's a very adult-like manga ?
For me that's very refreshing..
in a..in a sense..
I don't..it really..this shouldn't even matter but I..
to me..it feels like, they resp- they takes itself, more seriously..
in a way..
because, all the..let's be honest..
Japanese people are fucking perverts
I mean, everyone is
Just Japanese people are more honest about it
The fact that there's no weird sexual undertone..
or stuff like that..
to distract you from the story
It's just really nice *laugh*
If there's anything I would recommend from..this..video
Check out "Blame"..
If you wanna read something kinda like..
stark undertone sci-fi stories
I recommend it
I don't know why, this..
this is just so painfully awkward for me to..
talk about..
cause it really..uhm..
it really..I think it really will shine through in this video *giggle*
how fucking embarrassed I am right now *giggle awkwardly*
But anyway, I hope you enjoy this video..
if it even makes it light of day, I don't know
But..
Regardless..
maybe it was something different
I hope you enjoyed it
Uhm..
Lemme know
If you have any recommendation based on what I just talked about..
maybe there's something I missed
And yeah lemme know what you thought if you checked out any of my suggestions
It's always cool to see if people enjoy what you like
and stuff like that
I feel like I should re-do this video..
But I..I don't think I..
I can bear..
I-I don't think I can bear to do- to go through this painful experience again
*laugh*
I hope it wasn't painful for you
It was for me
Lemme tell you
Okay, that's it for now
*kiss fist*
Stay awesome bros. *brofists*